hi ladies hello how's it going
you know here we are here we are
now i don't know if i should admit this
working in entertainment media but
i haven't actually seen one flew over
the cuckoo's nest i know that's terrible
just say i know the movie sarah don't
hate me is there a leave
they're gonna leave them somewhere right
where i can please please stick with me
but sarah really for a character like
this obviously you need to
be omash the character and honor that
character but there's gonna be some
audience like me that don't know that
character at all so how do you find that
balance of
you know being faithful but also
realizing that some people don't know
the character
i've decided you're the anomaly you're
the outlier you're the outlier
um i'm the one god or the one guy in the
universe who's not seen the movie um
i don't know that the that ultimately
the the balance is up to me
i think there's an inherent interest
from most people
unlike yourself who's actually seen the
movie and cares about it to some degree
uh who will bring their own opinion
about it uh to the show
and then becomes kind of like an
interactive experience in a way because
then they have to kind of
meet their own feelings about her as
they watch the show and they may find
themselves
um coming to terms with a different
opinion about mildred
or at the very least understanding some
of her motivations which i think are far
purer than
than i'm not saying her deeds are pure
right
but but there is a purity to to uh what
she's seeking
what her one is yeah now judy i didn't
think we're gonna get another iconic
scene involving a peach
after call me by my name but call me by
your name but
we have one in this the show it's just
amazing how did you guys
approach that scene because that scene
is instantly iconic that fight over
peach
this peach thing i loved another one for
a while
for a while there there wasn't going to
be a peach because um
the props guy came up and said that
there aren't
peaches are not in season and can we use
another fruit
and i said well what and they said well
maybe a banana
and i said no no no no no no it has to
be a peach
yeah because it's the word peach it's
yeah
so they had to became this massive
search for
peaches and then on the day there was so
many peaches
all of them utterly taste this because
of course they were out of season but
i don't know i think it's to do with the
word peach
right it's so mundane in a way yeah but
it's such an amazing basically you heard
it here first you can thank judy for the
fact
that the world will have the peach scene
because you can't write your name on a
banana does not
it's true because i think you can yeah
you can then write your name on a banana
actually
yeah now i think uh
sarah ryan said to you that you're gonna
have to go like walter white a little
bit
in this role like prepare yourself i was
thinking that uh laura linney's wendy on
ozark was like the new walter white but
but you definitely give her a run for
your money so was that
scary to get into to kind of delve into
that psyche
um that part i don't know what it says
about me that part didn't frighten me at
all
um i felt more uh anxious about how to
contend with the
the preconceived idea about her and
whether i would even have a
fighting chance you know to do anything
worthwhile um
that was more of a personal concern of
mine
um but i think the walter white uh
sentiment that he was expressing was the
amount i would be working
american on american horror story i get
to play a different character every year
so
you know if i like a character or feel
particularly connected to one i'm done
with it by the end of the season and he
said this is just going to be something
that you're going to have to continue to
revisit and you're going to be tired
because you'll be working a lot and he
wasn't sure i really wanted to do that
and guess what
he was kind of right
and judy i mean sarah's done i've lost
track of how many ryan murphy projects
that you've done
sarah but judy this is your second one i
loved feud as well i love that series
so how would you explain as an actor how
would you explain
a ryan murphy world like getting into
that world as an actor
as an actor um
well the challenge uh for me was to
understand the tone that that the
writers were
were playing with and and it changed
you know because you don't read all the
scripts right at the start so
um with it every episode that comes out
you're gonna
have been throwing a curveball which
then you then have to incorporate it's
it's
it's almost like a a game it's a
great but there will be things in it
that are quite
challenging which is wonderful
yeah that's absolutely true well
congratulations on this i promise i'll
go watch
one flew over the cuckoo's nest as soon
as we're done here okay thanks for
hanging out hanging up sarah i
appreciate it
bye have a good day
you